- Our first guest today
is one of our favorites,
partly because he always
brings a new baby animal
every time he is here.
I love this.
Um his new show, coincidentally,
is called Animal Control
and it premieres tonight on Fox.
Give it up for Joel McHale everybody.
(crowd cheering)
(Rock Music)
- I told ya.
(Kelly squealing)
It's
Keep it coming, keep it coming.
Look at this,
it's a sloth!
- I'm so happy right now.
Hi.
- Okay. Can't pet his head though.
- Don't?
- Well, it's fine.
- Okay.
- Here, you can pet here.
- Okay, okay, okay.
I was like is he going to bite me?
(Kelly laughing)
- He'll go like, "it's food!"
He'll think it's food.
- Oh.
- Hi, yeah.
See?
Look.
- Don't you wanna snuggle?
- It's a sloth guys.
You're taking him home.
Congratulations. You've won the sloth.
- I know,
I already warned my team.
Am I gonna take a sloth home?
I don't know.
- Yeah.
- Oh my gosh.
- Do you wanna hold him?
- I really do.
- All right, here we go.
Well, I'll get, it uh
- Oh, hi. Hello
- So watch, this is his food,
which is lettuce and vodka.
- Totally.
- And uh, here if you sit
- Okay, okay.
- I'll give them to you.
- Oh my God, I'm so excited.
Wait.
Okay, okay.
- This is a tree sloth everybody.
as opposed to the
- Okay.
As opposed to?
- I, you know,
- A ground sloth?
- A ground sloth, which are extinct.
Oh, that's a great fun fact.
(laughing)
So, um yeah,
if you uh, if you, yeah
you can give him a
little, oh, look at this.
Check this out guys.
- God, I'm so happy.
- Yeah, look at that.
Can you get a read on that?
Look at that.
- Oh, do you feel at home?
- Kelly can't even see
the joke on my arms.
(crowd laughing)
- I can't.
Wait.
Eighth appearance.
(Kelly laughing)
- Yeah!
Thank you.
(crowd applauding)
- This is your eighth appearance?
- Can't believe it.
Yeah.
- Oh my God.
I love when you come.
- I like, this is so great,
cause Kelly doesn't care.
This is great.
Cuz you're like, Hey, no one, who, oh, who
- Who cares about Joel who brings animals.
- Who cares?
Let's just keep, yeah.
And there you go.
Look at that guys.
Have you ever seen anything this cute?
And,
A lot of people think they're uh,
you know, they smell.
They don't.
- They don't smell.
- Yeah, they smell like Jasmine.
- Jasmine.
- They they don't. They don't
- They don't smell like Jasmine.
- You just walked right into that
(crowd laughing)
- But they don't smell.
Probably cuz it's hard
to clean themselves.
They're so slow about it.
(crowd laughing)
- That, they're a little slow.
But you know,
they are three times stronger
than the human being.
And I am not kidding.
They can, oh
they can basically hang
from a tree indefinitely.
- Oh my God.
- No joke.